welcome to this video and this is a
15-minute game yeah after a long break
from those kind of videos a rapid game
15 minute zero increment unfortunately
but let's see what we can do a Dutch
defense originally i wanted to post um
the second part of my the good the bad
and the ugly mini-series on my Majorca
tournament but when I analyzed one of
the games i came i really didn't come to
a conclusion about one particular
endgame and so I don't want to make the
video without being completely sure
about about this this game this position
so I'm doing a rapid game instead and I
will do the second part of my tournament
coverage tomorrow so let's see we have
got a kind of a freestyle that share
maybe a position that never ever was on
the board before in a game yeah I don't
really have a great weapon against the
Dutch I think that Bishop g5 is not bad
but i don't really know it that well
let's see yeah Bishop c4 has a simple
idea just prevent castles and ask black
Hawaii how is going to set up his his
pieces yeah he success one idea yeah h4
h5 or not hmm come on let's let's try
try to weaken his King side structure
but yeah taking it's not a good idea
gives black good dark squared control
but h5 looks head does not look like
okay get it in easily hmm yeah I had
this kind of positions before and it's
not that great really
black white often gets in a five and I'm
not really sure if I pieces are well
placed then hmm can I have to look at
something decent against this opening
this is really not not any good maybe I
get an EVO at least at the moment even
that is maybe maybe I'm threatening you
form efore takes Knight takes Knight
takes Queen takes d5 I've got Quinn g6
check so I'm not running into a fork
that's a bit of a shaky position however
for what yeah what about you form this
is a move on is it is it bad yeah my
development is not very good I mean and
that's the wrong word but there is no no
big harmony in my position see find a
form those pieces are kind of loose but
if I don't play you form what is my move
actually he's going whoa going with e5
if I if I go E 4 is also night h5 taking
d 4 + F forum Chim if he for if it takes
two times and place castles it's also
not not so great d for FY is attacked
and he's threatening d5 with the fog mmm
yeah not very nice ok trying to prevent
if I for the moment and go from them
I don't like this position you have this
happen to me before in this line when
they play with g6 Bishop g7 I don't
really know how to play that this night
92 and again Bishop c4 is probably just
not a good idea now black might even
yeah exactly just played this I Knight
a5
yeah the only thing that this does
neglect the center a little bit okay
let's let's try to to open up the center
Chang
yeah Bishop e3 s-sir is blundering with
it but f-for so i have to go here right
edge 500 is playing that very very
quickly this is my one day this is good
f form therefore as a move that strikes
me as somewhat strange after 5i can also
go G form but then you might take and
play ma 5 i'm going to play five this
makes us bishop this night a little bit
city looking also this bishop on g7 is a
little bit strange now Wow
hmm ok that's it's a move that I didn't
expect at all so g-form yeah ok this is
something that I thought I should do I
mean it gets this this end and
threatening g4 winning this piece means
that he has to play some some strange
move to even keep the peace yeah all of
this is not a strange move per se but
it's looking looking looking strange ok
so if i go g4 night f4 Queen III Queen
III looks more natural all right just
threatening g-form yeah let's do that
threaten EG for winning the peace
Queen f7 what do i do then look f1 would
be fantastic if I could get in before
night b3 yeah this would completely
completely am gathers would be a
fantastic bind on this position
slightly mystify tiem is here is there
any alternative to Queen f7 want to see
thinking about as Queen f7 I mean good
or bad probably have to play it
otherwise g4 just wins the piece I mean
there is nothing I don't don't see any
other move that Queen f7 but let's check
this Queen f7 look H to f1 attending
what exactly night e 1 and G forum the
winning the winning the night then maybe
c5 but I can just take this pawn for the
night deform yeah I probably Queen f7
isn't saving and saving him Adam look H
to f1 right or is luke and I look D to
have one I'm sorry all look H somewhat
better now that that looks right and
that looks right the rook on the edge
file might might be used for some time
for h5 or move like that and I'm
threatening 91 that's the that's yeah
I'm okay that was a stronger move rope d
to f 1 this is actually the main threat
yeah nighty one Queen Queen away and
then G form if he goes to e7 I have to
be aware of things like takes on g4 I
mean let's say I don't know what you
should do now any move and then nitey
one queen is 7g for I have to be aware
of takes on everyone and takes on H form
that might be something that is still a
bit tricky at times Oh
think about that move yeah okay it frees
it frees the g7 square so um let's think
about this for a moment just just on
edge six right it's no reason not to
take this I'm also threatening here g4
and then night gt5 okay so we just have
a queen trade or by the way the queen is
blocking the night again so I can also
drop back to e3 ever want
yeah that's probably better rod what is
there I mean the traders is very nice
for wine now does this must be better
g-form is still threatened so G 497 and
then again queen age 64 95 it's pretty
good yeah now 95 is very serious ng6
hangs yeah that's it I don't think I
don't see any kind of Defense iam yeah I
think he had a really nice position but
then made some some somewhat
questionable decisions okay um 95 on
Queen g6 Jack let's let's take this bus
chick man i cannot be too bad yeah just
the endgame
yeah let's just let's just take this end
game just two points for absolutely
nothing it is still as badly coordinated
pieces so let's see what's the cleanest
way to win this I think before for night
be 32 c 5 x looks very very convincing
on okay let's take it so night be three
if i go to see Five now he has the check
Kim D 2 and then look f3 maybe I can
take a one then he so it should work
right
hmm
yeah but it's not necessary really I
have fun I can also just go here here
first and go from there yeah now 95 how
does he protect this bishop rd seven is
to go back to to see 8 pro level and now
what is what is the easiest way to do it
95 that's probably bishop age 6 which
sort of hangs on for a little bit yeah
so maybe just g5 and so on
I just wonder what the quickest quickest
way is b3 is also not not particularly
bad yeah come on let's let's be lazy and
protect the pawn and g5 91-93 this kind
of thing you cannot move any office
pieces really
yeah that idea's night d three light one
d3 to be for winning c 6 193 f for this
kind of things there are multiple ways
to win this position of course just have
to make sure that he's getting no
counter play on any any trickery but
it's difficult to gain something as
black e'er just so passive
yeah taking a 95 back maybe one had
before I go night before now here so
going to be sick see that's our kind of
funny one is there is there something
else we should f/4g if I was also good
yeah maybe that one pill activate the
somewhat clumsy h2 bishop on f6 is a
nice nice position for it
all right okay wants to go wants to go
to F 7 a.m. okay
yep trading this is certainly helpful
yeah so g5 point so age 6 yeah it gets
kinda nice now with the sports it's a
bit too much okay so f 7044 g6 chicken
black resigns yeah I'm some coming a
challenge let's uh let's have a look at
this game yeah I don't really like this
opening I mean I have to have to really
look up how this is properly played here
he chose a good setup this was this was
really ok this d6 Queenie 7 that's a
good setup it's not so easy for wide
because those pieces there in the center
but he's getting if Ivan and it looks it
looks a bit uncomfortable I was thinking
about a form but one thing that made me
rethink this was this weary five is a
threat and f4 is under pressure seems
that this is okay though the whole idea
is however questionable because of a
five anyway this is the problem those
pawns they keep going forward and yeah
it is all it's very awkward I have to do
stuff like that and this is really not
what I want this is a strong Center yeah
I went went with this this is just good
right
we can hear he has a five in reserve he
doesn't need to do it quickly and just
long castles is not bad I'm not saying
that this is bad i'm just saying that
this was easier yeah I don't know this
kind of thing a form check take sticks
and around here there is there a
certainly room for improvement this
going back and f4 is a definite mistake
that is a mistake because it basically
killed 22 pieces the night on h5 and the
Bishop g7 I think he had probably better
alternatives before but well if he just
castles this is not a good position ER
Black has got two bishops he's got a5 a4
as an idea and it's not clear what my
pieces are doing this is a very stupid
piece and this is I think all of a
sudden nice for wide and it gets even
worse after d 5 which he played
relatively quickly and this is really a
horrible move it gives up on any hope of
counter play whatsoever it stabilizes
the center and after g4 he's already in
in concrete trouble am with this g4 idea
trapping the night that's its own
computer is on 1.3 and climbing wants to
play G hive now which is already kind of
desperate this and then yeah g4 is also
good maybe stronger you but it is a win
in any case this is this is just too bad
you had your playing with those two off
side pieces on g7 and h5 it's impossible
to hold yeah g4 was also strong this
this 91 you know
but okay you could you just take that
and and it's it's a win basically and
now Knight g4 threatened she has to do
this yeah and now our age five they are
they are all good but just taking it
that is a clean and simple simple
solution and here there are multiple
ways to win a good recipes always this
don't rush now we white is so winning
you can improve step-by-step some pieces
and then think about how to how to do it
I probably could have one quick of it
this was a very very simple convenient
way to do it after Bishop takes I'm
taking here chango g6 check no it's a
it's made in a couple of moves yeah but
I have to really am yeah refresh this
opening it wasn't a good opening result
ok I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this rapid game thanks for watching